[MUSIC]
NLM has a wonderful mission, and that
was definitely one of the reasons
why I found NLM to be an attractive
place to work, and it's a
00:00:14,700 --> 00:00:14,100
big reason why I'm still here.
NLM's mission--down to its most pure
kernel--and that's to remind everybody
that everything that you do here
everyday helps somebody to get
health information.
Often people ask me,
"Why the government?"
Or "Why the National
Library of Medicine?"
"Why not Google?"
"Why not Apple?"
And while they are great companies--
and they are doing great research--
NLM offers the blend, which
excites me, that I can work with
more than one field at the same time.
And the idea of actually training
computers to help doctors, help
researchers, help teachers, educators,
in the role of the library was exciting
enough that I wanted to be here.
There are many well-respected and
well-regarded medical libraries,
but being part of NLM is like
playing the big room. I mean,
this is about as good as it gets.
This is not the run of the mill
administrative office; It is a
research institution pushing
the boundaries for informatics.